hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to a
video edition of ask Evan in today's
video I want to answer a question for
one my readers jockey who's concerned
about the recession and is feeling that
people are spending less money on
everyday items which is hurting a lot of
small business owners who rely on those
consumers and so Jack was asking how can
we overcome this is entrepreneurs is
there a way to generate more business so
answer for you Jackie is yes people are
spending less but they are still
spending money and so it's up to you to
really differentiate your business from
everybody else to win that market share
so even though there's less money out
there there is still money there to be
had so here's a compliance view that
will hopefully help you solve your
problem the first is you want to offer
really great customer service be as
helpful as you can try to reach out and
connect with your customers as much as
you can and try to build a relationship
with them so it's harder for them to
jump ship and soph mine from your go buy
from someone else might be a little bit
cheaper because they feel they have a
really strong relationship with you so
do your customers really care about you
and it starts with you caring about them
first so as much as you can you want to
try to be really super helpful for your
customers go above and beyond with your
service if it's just you that's great
but also your staff if you have it try
to be as helpful as possible so you want
to build that relationship so that's the
first step the next thing I would
recommend is try to make it really easy
for people to bar from you and to say
yes so you might want to think about
having an introductory offer for example
have something that's low cost is an
entry-level gateway to start to work
with your business and that way you can
show what a great product or service you
have what great service you have on top
of it and how helpful you and your team
are and that helps start to build the
customer loyalty so if you have a really
high ticket price items their way to
make it a little bit cheaper have an
entry level offering so that people can
start to do business with you and
realize what a great company you are the
third thing I recommend is trying to get
some social proof in there nobody wants
to be the first to buy and there's
probably tons of
for whatever you are no buying or
selling so what you want to try to do is
show that people really like what you're
up to so try to get testimonials from
some of your customers try to use social
media and get people you know liking you
and giving you some tweets about your
business and the more you can showcase
that and show new prospective customers
that you know they're not going to be
the first ones to buy from you the
greater the chance is that you're going
to be able to lay that new business
instead of your competition so I hope
that helps don't get too discouraged it
is tough times and it can be really hard
to sell to people when you know they're
not spending as much money but they are
still spending money so don't lose hope
and you know focusing on your business
to try to get those customers as much as
you can I hope you liked the video if
you did please give the thumbs up below
I'd also love to hear your thoughts of
feedback if you want to leave a comment
below and stay tuned for the next
episode
you